los incendios forestales en el mundo
serán cada vez más frecuentes así lo
alerta un nuevo informe del programa de
naciones unidas para el medio ambiente
los responsables la deforestación masiva
de bosques el aumento del calor global o
las sequías exacerbadas por la crisis
climática que anticipan que para 2050
los incendios extremos aumenten un 30% y
un 50% para finales de siglo los
incontrolables y devastadores incendios
forestales se están convirtiendo en una
parte esperada de nuestros calendarios
estacionales los incendios forestales se
producen en todos los continentes
excepto en la antártida y la mayoría de
regiones experimentan condiciones
meteorológicas propicias para la
aparición de un incendio forestal en
algún momento los incendios afectan de
manera desproporcionada a las naciones
más empobrecidas con un impacto
económico devastador para las
comunidades territorios enteros
calcinados por las llamas desde asia
hasta américa como en argentina donde
las últimas semanas el fuego asoló la
provincia de corrientes con un 9 por
ciento del territorio arrasado
lo que vemos en muchas regiones del
mundo es que la mayoría de estos
recursos se destinan a la respuesta por
lo que la mayor parte de lo que hacen
los gobiernos y las políticas se centra
en el corto plazo es reactivo y por lo
tanto no es proactivo
el documento plantea un cambio radical
en el gasto de los gobiernos en
incendios forestales cambiando sus
inversiones de reacción y respuesta a
prevención y preparación con la fórmula
fire ready y es que actualmente la mayor
inversión está destinada a la respuesta
directa